il n'en restait plus qu'un et c'était
celui-là un port du nord ça plaît
surtout quand on n'est pas ça fait qu'on
voudrait y être ça fait qu'on ne sait
pas bien s'il faut se taper le poète ou
stap et la [ __ ] bon ya pas que des
buteurs où il n'y a pas que des marins
où il ya des chiens perdus et des
enfants des rues où il n'ya pas de
démarche en où il n'y a pas que des
challenges où il ya des vieux chevaux
qui bridge avec la mort où il ya des
flics chinois qui se prennent pour la
reine et puis les filles en soi qui font
couler leur gaine sur le bord du
trottoir comme un chagrin de plus qui
traînera ce soir tout le long de la rue
sur moi
ça pouvait ressembler à rotterdam où il
ya des rats crevés comme bien à paris où
il ya des chats croisés avec des
vieilles souris où il n'ya pas de
l'import ou y'a bien loin du bord des
amants qui se font et puis qui se défend
où il n'y a pas que des banques note au
seuil des mini jupes et des mecs qui
s'occupent à placer leur camelote où il
ya des malheureux qui donneraient leur
cul si on donne en sont qu on était bien
sur moi ça pouvait ressembler à
rotterdam où il ya des assassins planqué
dans leur whisky et puis d insensée qui
passeront pas la nuit où il n'y a pas
que du tabac au goût de caramel il ya de
pauvres soldats qui se farcir elle
carmel oui un crise de 2002 hier un bar
de nuit qui cause avec le bout avec le
bout de la nuit où il ya des exilés qui
sortent leur exil dans le ciel barbelés
d'une publicité qu'on
sur moi ça pouvait ressembler à
rotterdam
oui
je
mais comme je vais sans soleil où tu
n'iras jamais carte atout c'est pareil
je prends très du sud
tu demandes aux traits du sud il prend
le train du sud jusqu'au bout de la nuit
sur moi
ça pouvait ressembler ali
tha
ali
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]